NICK BUTCHER: A little later
than advertised, you are
joining an Android Developers
Office Hours.
So we're coming to you
live from London.
And my name is the Nick Butcher,
and I'm joined by--
MATT GAUNT: Matt Gaunt.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Hey, and I'm
Richard Hyndman, also from the
Android Developer
Relations team.
NICK BUTCHER: So this your
opportunity to talk to us
about all things Android dev.
And as always, this is not an
opportunity to talk about
unreleased products, when is
x feature going to launch?
Why is Rich and Matt sharing
headphones like they're
teenagers on the bus?
MATT GAUNT: Are you giggling?
NICK BUTCHER: Those topics
will not be discussed.
But otherwise, yeah.
Come along and ask us
all things Android.
Yeah, so it looks like we're
joined by a couple of regular
watchers, who we've got
in the Hangout live.
Say hello.
AL SUTTON: Hey guys, it's Al.
MATT GAUNT: Hey Al,
how's it going?
Mr. Sutton.
NICK BUTCHER: Who
else do we have?
[INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Peter?
Peter Brooks there, I think,
and [INAUDIBLE].
Nice to see you all.
Thanks for joining.
All right, then.
I'd better go and mute
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So is
there any news?
Anything in the news at
the moment that we
want to talk about?
Exciting Android developments?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Something
since Maps [INAUDIBLE]?
AL SUTTON: [INAUDIBLE]
API.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'm still just,
like, up here on the
fact that Android apps
can have awesome maps
in them right now.
NICK BUTCHER: So yeah, Billing
V2 has launched.
Has anyone had a chance to look
at the new, streamlined,
easier way to make
in-app payments?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I have.
MATT GAUNT: Yep.
I've been playing with it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Matt's been
playing with it, as well.
NICK BUTCHER: What do
you think of it?
Much improved?
MATT GAUNT: Yes.
NICK BUTCHER: Many, many fewer
lines of code to implement.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
Much, much simpler,
much, much easier.
Training's really
good as well.
Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You can do the
whole thing in 50 lines of
code now, which isn't too bad.
NICK BUTCHER: There's been a
lot of the feedback I've
heard, that the developers love
the kind of monetization
opportunities it affords them
but find it hard to implement.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: In
the old version.
NICK BUTCHER: In the old
version-- the old version.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And you can
finally request the pricing
information from
the Play store.
So inline inside your
application, you can say, buy
a sword for $0.99.
And when you put sales on in the
Play store, it just comes
down to your application.
NICK BUTCHER: Yep.
You don't have to synchronize
a change to your SKU price
list with an update to
your app and hope the
user gets the update.
So the app can see
the right price.
It's much simpler.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Hopefully that
reduces the number of
cancellations as well, because
they can see the price in your
app before going through to the
Play store and finding out
the cost of the in-app item.
OK.
I haven't checked today's
moderator out, but I'm sure we
have some questions on it.
NICK BUTCHER: Are there any
questions from people in the
Hangout, before we jump
into the moderator?
AL SUTTON: I've got one, but I
don't know whether you guys
can actually answer it.
It's based on the new
Android tools.
There's a new license term.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
AL SUTTON: They can't
be used for doing
fragmentation of Android.
Is there any guidance on what
would be considered
fragmentation?
NICK BUTCHER: Say that again.
There was a lot of noise during
the middle of that.
Would you mind repeating?
AL SUTTON: Sure.
The new Android toolkit for,
I think it's for 4.2, has a
clause in the license that
says it can't be used for
anything that would contribute
to fragmentation.
Is there anywhere that we can
get guidance on what would be
considered fragmentation
and what's not?
NICK BUTCHER: So you're talking
about the Terms Of
Service, which sounds like it's
a lot like a voyage into
lawyer land, which I am not
qualified to make any kind of
a judgment upon.
It's a good question, though.
So that was the change in the
Terms of Service you agreed to
when you updated ADT, right?
AL SUTTON: Yeah, those ones.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know.
Have you posted this in the
tools development forum?
AL SUTTON: I have, and there was
a discussion in the tools
development.
Because if you build the tools
from the Open Source Project
you're, of course, not bound
by the same license.
So there was a lot of to-ing
and fro-ing on that.
But it's just, basically,
looking for a definition of
what fragmentation means
in that context.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Yeah, that's a good question,
which unfortunately, I don't
think, any of us even know or
are qualified to weigh in on,
unfortunately.
How could we get an
answer to that?
I guess maybe we email the
PM for that project and
try and find out?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We could try.
Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Leave
it with us.
We'll try and follow
up on that for you.
AL SUTTON: Cool, thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: No problem.
Any other live questions
in the room?
PETER BROOKS: A very
quick one.
Well, I think very quick.
In terms of Google Play error
codes, do you guys know, or
does anyone else know, these
kind of 914 error codes which
we had yesterday throughout
the entire market or 948?
They seem really kind of random,
and we would love to
tell our users what's
wrong with them
buying our apps, really.
NICK BUTCHER: All I know is that
there was an outage at
some point, and it
got resolved.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] some payment--
PETER BROOKS: OK.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --had
been declined for
some reason or other.
It was showing the 914 error.
We had quite a lot of partners
reporting it.
[INAUDIBLE].
PETER BROOKS: Right.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, as to is
there anything, actually, you
can do in your app?
No, I don't think there's any.
We don't publish these error
codes and advise any kind of
response to put to the user.
I'd say just catch them
gracefully and say,
there was an error.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We update the
known issues page, as well.
If you do a Google search of
Google Play developer known
issues, we work pretty hard
making sure that page is
updated so at least you can show
your users that it's our
problem, not yours.
PETER BROOKS: Right, OK.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Cheers.
Thanks, Peter.
NICK BUTCHER: Is this
the first Hangout
you're doing, Peter?
Have you been a lurker for a
while, or first time joining?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Don't
ask people that.
PETER BROOKS: I lurked last week
and only just found out
about it recently.
So I'll join you guys
in the future.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Cool.
NICK BUTCHER: Yep,
spread the word.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You're
more than welcome.
AL SUTTON: We can post it in
the Android developer's
community on Google+.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, we should.
We've got some more people
seem to have
joined us, as well.
Who else have we got there?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Hugo's joined in.
NICK BUTCHER: Ah.
Mr. Visser.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And
Giuseppe of course.
HUGO VISSER: Hi guys.
NICK BUTCHER: Hi.
MATT GAUNT: Hi there.
NICK BUTCHER: Hugo, I think
you had a question in the
moderator, right?
HUGO VISSER: I actually
had two.
But the most important one was
the one that I already posted
on Google+ a while ago.
And it was a question about
the voice recognition, the
streaming stuff.
I couldn't find any
documentation on it, but what
I would like to do is what the
Google Now app is doing is,
like, listen for a certain
kind of word.
So I think the voice recognition
could be useful
for that, but I'm not sure if
I can start it in a sort of
streaming background
way in my app.
NICK BUTCHER: There's no
way to do it, really.
The only way you can do
it is by throwing up
the recognition dialogue.
There's no kind of background
recognition.
HUGO VISSER: AUDIENCE: OK, so it
would also require a custom
IME or something like that?
NICK BUTCHER: Quite possibly.
I don't even know if you'd
be successful that way.
I think the custom IME froze
up the standard UI, right?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It does.
Yep.
So you can either do
fixed-length detection and
then process that and then go
back [INAUDIBLE], procedures,
like check every 30 seconds and
then cancel it and start
again, which is not ideal.
Or go with [INAUDIBLE], but then
you're not going to know
when [INAUDIBLE].
HUGO VISSER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I agree.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [? Predrag's ?]
just come in.
[? MATT GAUNT: Predrag? ?]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: He's just come
in from the Hangout post.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
Excellent.
And you had a second
question, Hugo?
HUGO VISSER: Yeah.
But that's regarding the
new billing API.
Just a confirmation.
I assume that in the new
billing API, your old
purchases will also
pop up, right?
Like if you have managed
purchases.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
was compatible.
But new items that you should
create now should be managed.
HUGO VISSER: Right.
Because I read some comments
on Twitter
that something broke.
But I'm not sure
what to think.
I thought, let's ask.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I saw that
as well, [? by Raoul. ?]
He said something broke.
HUGO VISSER: Yeah,
he said that.
So I'm not sure what's
going on there.
But from what I understand
later, that he's still using
the older API, and that
broke for him.
But I haven't noticed
that in my app yet.
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
So we shouldn't
have changed anything.
If you're still saying V1 or V2,
it should still have V1 or
V2 functionality.
It's only as soon as you specify
V3 that you'll get the
new functionality.
HUGO VISSER: Yeah.
OK, cool.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Cool.
NICK BUTCHER: So are there any
more live questions in the
room, or should we jump
into the moderator?
AUDIENCE: I want to ask
you why the Android is
the best over iOS?
NICK BUTCHER: So why should
you develop for
Android rather than iOS?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: I guess it's the
world's largest software and
mobile operating system, is a
pretty compelling reason.
I would say, if reach is
important to you, then, that's
a good reason.
AUDIENCE: I have a good article
if he wants to read.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, stick
it into the chat window.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, still getting
the hang of this.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's OK.
Top-left corner, you should have
a little Chat button, and
you can press it.
And the window will open up.
AUDIENCE: It's an article from
three years ago, but it's
still pretty good.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No, no.
It's exponentially
more important.
NICK BUTCHER: What
is it they say?
75% of all smart phones
shipping run Android?
That's a pretty strong
reason, I think.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There's
a lot of good reasons.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the biggest
reason for me is that you
don't need wait two,
three weeks to
get your app in store.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, but
that's [? not for ?]
publication.
AUDIENCE: It's especially crazy
if you want to publish
up the existing app.
You know, like Apple's App
Store, there are people that
abandoned their app, because
Apple [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, you're in
control of your own software
release cycles, which
is awesome.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And it's a
whole ecosystem, as well.
It's not just controlled
by one company.
We have all the OEMs, the
operators, the handset
manufacturers, the developers,
people with their own music
stores, their own app stores.
Everything [INAUDIBLE]
Android to create this
massive ecosystem.
People working together
to create something.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: Whoa,
massive feedback.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
I think this is a pretty
open-ended
question, which really--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, it's
been a long time since
someone has asked why.
It's more the how, now.
How do I do x?
But thanks for the question.
Hopefully there was some
convincing arguments for you.
Any more live questions,
or should we go
back into the moderator?
MARIJN OOSTERVELD: I have
a question, which
is also in the moderator.
It's about a three-pane view
which I would like to
implement, just like
Gmail has.
So one on the left side and
one on the right side.
And if you choose any content
on the right side, you get
this slider, which just slides
over one of those fragments.
And then there's some
other content.
Without using any external
library.
NICK BUTCHER: So you want
to build it yourself.
Yeah, so basically these will
just be fragment animations.
MARIJN OOSTERVELD: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: So every time
you kind of-- you know in
Gmail, so when you select an
individual message, it'll
queue up a set of animations
where it'll slide out the
label view and slide
in the detail view.
MARIJN OOSTERVELD: OK, is there
an example or any code
available to try something
like that out?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Sure there is.
One that was really good is
the Romain Guy published
something called xlarge-demos.
If you Google for Romain
Guy, xlarge-demos--
this was launched a while back
now when Honeycomb just
launched, but it was a really
nice demonstration of how to
use fragments and how to
animate them around.
Since then, the animation API
has only got better and
stronger and faster and so on.
So there's a few improvements
that you can use, things like
adapters and so on.
[INAUDIBLE].
MARIJN OOSTERVELD: OK.
So that was x super?
NICK BUTCHER: Sorry, I think
the demo is something like
xlarge-demos, you know,
like the screen
size modifier, xlarge.
MARIJN OOSTERVELD: OK.
Thank you so much.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
you're welcome.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Android 3
animation demos, maybe.
NICK BUTCHER: Hello,
Mr. Banes.
CHRIS BANES: Hey guys.
NICK BUTCHER: You have a
time shifted version
of us in your window.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Any other
questions live from the
Hangout, or should we crack
on with the moderator?
[INAUDIBLE].
No?
OK, cool.
So Timothy Kist in Swansea says,
how can I show that the
user can't swipe a certain
way in a view
page by over scrolling?
How do I force over scrolling
when the view page
is not at the end?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: What
would you use?
You'd use the [? force field ?]
for this, right?
NICK BUTCHER: I don't understand
what do you mean
when the view page is
not at the end.
So you want to kind of
arbitrarily cut them off
before they can get to the end,
the last views, perhaps?
MATT GAUNT: It kind of sounds
like if you had a wizard, you
might not want to enable them to
go to the third pane until
they completed certain criteria
on the second pane.
So my guess would be to just
do this in the adapter, do
some tricky stuff just to say
there's only two view pages.
And then once they've completed
it, then fire off
and change the adapter,
let's say, OK, now
the third one's available.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Do you know how
[? Raoul ?] did it in the
wizard template view?
NICK BUTCHER: You can
always [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's
[INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, you could override
the on touch as well--
the on-touch events-- and just
decide whether or not you're
going to pass them through
to the ViewPager.
So if they have not completed
the requisite, whatever item's
on the form, just
hold onto them.
NICK BUTCHER: That's a good
argument, actually.
If you haven't done it, it's
really, really worth taking a
look at the ViewPager sources.
Incredibly readable, and you'll
learn a lot about how
to create custom views.
But, yeah if you look at the
section where it's just a
touch drag, and it decides
whether to tell the data to
give you a new view or not.
You could do it then.
Just invoke the edge effect
stuff instead to get the
[? force field ?] clear
At that point.
Hopefully that's the answer
to your question.
Yeah, the AdapterView sounds
like the right way to go so.
Al seems to be going through
and adding timed YouTube
responses to each of
the questions.
That's very [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
[STATEMENT REPEATS]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The
Chris Banes delay.
AL SUTTON: Just in
case I missed it
the first time round.
CHRIS BANES: Rich, you seem to
be in the Hangout twice.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I am, yes.
Hey, hey.
NICK BUTCHER: Double
Rich this week.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: That's what
happens when we're unprepared
and we get to campus late.
NICK BUTCHER: So there's a
question here from Giuseppe.
Do you want to unmute and
ask us live, Giuseppe?
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
Hello.
NICK BUTCHER: How do I send
a file over Bluetooth?
GIUSEPPE: Hello?
NICK BUTCHER: Little joke for
the [INAUDIBLE] watching.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We can hear
you fine, Giuseppe.
Hi.
GIUSEPPE: Good, good, good.
I just put my [INAUDIBLE]
question to
the moderator's panel.
If you want, I can ask here.
I would like to know in the case
of a situation, where LVL
license failed, I mean that,
actually, we have about 20,000
real users that paid
the application.
But because we have a back-end
server, we know that there are
about 300,000 users that they
just downloaded the
application from Aptoide.
Is Aptoide just a center
of crackers?
They remove they LVL license
from the application, and they
make downloadable the
application from everybody.
The bad situation at the moment
is that the Play Store
is making possible this Aptoide
exist, as there is the
client on the Play Store.
And this is not very good.
What is your point of view?
I would like to know.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Well, first of all, there's the
pirates and vampires talk
from Google I/O, which explains
how to secure your
LVL past the standard
documentation that we have.
Securing LVL is a long
and in-depth topic.
If you put more effort into it,
but it's worth cracking
your application--
especially in your case where
you have quite a valuable
application--
hackers are going to spend more
time trying to break it
and get that valuable app
back out into the wild.
But as Hugo says, you've got
your own servers that each of
the applications
are porting to.
I would definitely try and
maintain the list of
authorized users on
those servers.
And whenever you get a pirated
app, you can just disable it
from the server.
AL SUTTON: Another thing that
I'd recommend is looking at
ProGuard or even going for
Eric Lafortune's more
commercial offering, DexGuard,
which is focused on Android.
That makes it more difficult to
extract out things like LVL
and other routines, and bits
and bobs like that.
So if the app hasn't been fed
through at least ProGuard,
then it's definitely worth
giving that a shot.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
Yeah, that's mentioned in
pirates and vampires.
Have you obfuscated your
app, Giuseppe?
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
Has it been obfuscated
with the ProGuard?
I have a mike on--
probably someone has the
microphone open.
I think, this guy.
NICK BUTCHER: We'll
try and find it.
GIUSEPPE: Uh, [? Patrick? ?]
[? Patrick? ?]
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
GIUSEPPE: OK, let's continue.
Well, the main solution, as
everybody knows here, is just
to use a back-end server.
I would like to use the back-end
server just to get to
each purchase, store the
purchase in our back-end
server, and through the account
manager, compare if
the user has been booked.
But in my special case, as you
remember, we can't use the API
of Checkout, because they're
available only
in UK and the USA.
And so this solution is
not applicable for us.
The code has been obfuscated.
Everything has been done.
The check license--
it's not always in any
update in the same
position of the code.
I used to change the position
of the license checking,
sometimes in some activity,
sometimes in some fragments,
sometimes somewhere else--
or some preference,
everywhere.
I tried all that my small mind
can suggest, but I didn't find
how to save it.
Well, someone told me, Giuseppe,
never mind about
these people, because the people
that crack it up will
never pay you for
the application.
Yes, that is a good
suggestion.
But the technical problem is
very important, because
actually, my back-end server,
it's giving, like downloading,
serving the information about.
So I have the 97% of the
users that are using my
[? artworks, ?]
my resource for zero,
for nothing.
That is the situation.
I believe that it's the
time to find some
solution for this problem.
That's all.
Probably mine could be not
the right question.
Seems to be not a question but
is a way, here, to open the
discussion between us.
That's it.
NICK BUTCHER: Hey, have
you tried verifying?
AUDIENCE: What is the name
of your application?
GIUSEPPE: Sorry,
[? Patrick? ?]
AUDIENCE: What is the name of
application, like, that you're
talking about?
GIUSEPPE: I believe that here is
not the right place to say
the names of our application.
We are not here for
advertising.
If you want later, I
would let you know.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah, I was just
curious, what [INAUDIBLE]
and the problem.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, if you go on
Aptoide website, then in the
music category, my application
is the first one.
So you cannot [? wrong. ?]
OK?
Simple.
NICK BUTCHER: So have
you tried the--
GIUSEPPE: I would like to say
that my application is the
first on the Play store, not
on the Aptoide store.
NICK BUTCHER: Have you tried all
the recommendations in the
talk Rich talked about, the talk
from Google I/O, "Evading
Pirates and Vampires,"
which talked about
exactly this problem?
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
NICK BUTCHER: So you tried
verifying the signatures of
the device on your server
and all this?
GIUSEPPE: Change this
[INAUDIBLE].
Change the numbers that, any
version I change the numbers?
No.
No way.
I tried to encrypt
the device ID.
I tried to encrypt the--
everything.
Everything I tried.
They just remove.
They just remove the check.
They find, where is my
do check, and they
then move the do check.
And then they return
through anytime.
It's very simple.
I have already downloaded
from Aptoide my APK.
And I understood very well,
how they do that.
So I can try to follow any
guidelines but I will not find
the solution if we continue
to use LVL as a system.
That's it.
AL SUTTON: Do you have a free
version of your application
and then allow people to
purchase while in app?
GIUSEPPE: No.
We haven't the free version.
AL SUTTON: Because that
might be a solution.
Because a lot of the times,
you'll find people are trying
the application out to
see if they like it.
Just taking it from another
perspective, it might be worth
switching to in-app payments
and offering a small free
trial to get people hooked in.
And then get them to buy once
they're happy that they like
the application, rather than
giving them the only choice of
pay up beforehand, or go and
get it from a pirate site.
GIUSEPPE: Yes, but Al, you must
agree with me that this
is just a workaround.
It's not the real solution
to the problem, right?
AL SUTTON: It's not a technical
solution to the problem.
But from the statistics I've
seen, there's a lot more
conversion to customers, a lot
more purchases, when you
switch to something like in-app
billing with the free
bit up the front.
Which could be a way to--
yeah, it won't cure the problem,
but you'll certainly
find that you're getting
a lot more paid
users on your server.
And so you may get to the stage
where you're talking
50-50 or even 80-20 paid
versus unpaid.
GIUSEPPE: Yes, that's
true, that's true.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I think
that's a great point.
GIUSEPPE: It's a good
suggestion, but frankly, I
hope that someday we can get
also the technical solution.
NICK BUTCHER: Do you have any
way of verifying which users
contacting your servers have
paid and which haven't?
Can you, for example,
look at a test on--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GIUSEPPE: Yes, I do that.
I do that.
I check each customer.
I know from where they
downloaded the application And
if they downloaded the APK
from the Google Market,
because they're a constant
inside the application.
But the only that I can do is,
when I upgrade to new version,
just to block the old version.
This is actually what
I am doing now.
But because the users demand
to use it to upgrade to the
new version very fast, sometime
I'm [INAUDIBLE] in
the problem to block users
that have paid for, too.
AL SUTTON: Have you looked at
check reporting the signature,
the APK file, to your server
and only responding to
requests from an APK
that's been signed
with the right signature?
GIUSEPPE: I lost you.
Can you repeat again please?
AL SUTTON: Sure.
Using the Package Manager, you
can get the signature for your
APK, or the APK that's
running.
Now, you should be able to
report that to your server,
and it will only report your
signature for application
versions which don't have your
check removed, ie, you've
authored and you've
distributed.
So if people are removing it
and re-signing the APK in
order to get it installed,
you'll probably find that the
signatures that get reported
to your server are not the
ones who are expected.
And so you could just block
those users straight off.
CHRIS BANES: The trouble with
that is that they can easily
replace that code and just
return what the proper
signature should be.
GIUSEPPE: Correct, Chris.
Correct.
CHRIS BANES: I don't think
you're ever going to fix it,
because it's always going
to be code, which
is out of your control.
It's always going to
be on their device.
They can always [INAUDIBLE]
to change it.
So you're never going to
completely fix it.
I think you just have to bite
the bullet and just accept it.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
Can I just put here one of my
idea, and each of us try to
see if it's correct?
When the device downloaded the
APK from the Play Store, the
Play Store knows the device
ID in that moment, OK?
What is the problem for Google
to give us in the back end
information--
the device ID?
Then we can collect this
device ID, we can store
somewhere in our server, and
to compare with the buyer?
I don't know if my question
is clear.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The problem is,
I think, [INAUDIBLE] for
the buyer, though,
you might have--
especially now with multiple
users on a single tablet,
multiple accounts on a single
tablet, it's the Gmail account
that's purchased it,
not the device.
NICK BUTCHER: And then how
would you use that?
You mean, you're proposing to
send the device ID with each
request to your server?
Because then you just get in the
same situation that Chris
talked about, where they'll
find a valid device ID and
just always send that.
GIUSEPPE: You mean they can
change the device ID too?
HUGO VISSER: No, they can
send the device ID,
which is not good.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Have you gone
as far-- because I know you've
used the NDK a lot in
your application.
But have you gone as far as
doing the APK signature checks
in the NDK, in the native
library that you compile off?
Because we would much rather
decompile than reconstruct
that part of the application.
And then just disable the
whole application if the
native library check fails.
Then you can check which
signature the app was signed
with, the hash of the
entire APK file, or
other things like that.
It's explained in the video.
GIUSEPPE: Richard, is there any
of the suggested solution
already working and guaranteed
that there would be not crack?
No.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Never, ever.
There's nothing in the
world that's not
been cracked, right?
Or has a secure system
for anything.
NICK BUTCHER: It's not a secure
computing platform.
You're not in control of
the hardware, right?
AL SUTTON: Nothing's
uncrackable.
GIUSEPPE: So we just make harder
for them to make this--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You need to
make it harder to crack it
than your application
is worth.
AL SUTTON: All of security
is just about an
effort-reward ratio.
And it's making the effort so
high and the reward so low
that people don't think
it's worth doing.
NICK BUTCHER: I really think
that the idea of going free
with in-app purchase is a
really, really good idea,
actually, as well.
I think, yeah, when you make
it so easy to get access to
the application and very
easy to pay to--
if you've proven that you like
it, then I think that removes
some of the curiosity-type
pirating.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, it's
just hard to figure out,
especially in this kind of
application, how much of the
functionality you give
away for free.
Because users will install it
expecting it to do a certain
amount of things.
And then you're like,
oh, to do that, you
need the pro upgrade.
Please buy it here for $0.99
or whatever it is.
So you've got to still get the
balance right, because you
could lose a lot of
ratings on it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, it's
not trivial, but
it's worth it, I think.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK?
GIUSEPPE: OK, thank
you very much.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Since then,
there's been a big
conversation going on in the
chat window that I haven't
been reading.
NICK BUTCHER: There is?
What's been going on, Rich?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I just don't
have an idea how they manage
to change obfuscated code.
Whenever I decompile an
obfuscated app, it's a mess.
[INAUDIBLE] says it's easy.
NICK BUTCHER: It's because
they're [? leet. ?]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Hackers
just rip out the
Android Java checks.
Check out the Droidcon
UK videos, for
example, for Apkudo.
HUGO VISSER: Yeah, there was a
presentation on hacking, Words
With Friends or something
like that?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, "Reverse
Engineering for Fun and
Profit" or something,
I think it's called.
HUGO VISSER: Yeah, it was a very
cool thing, but it also
shows how easy it is.
It's just the matter of time
that you put in it.
NICK BUTCHER: I think you need
a lot of this stuff, these
checks and NDKs Rich
suggested, also.
HUGO VISSER: And I'm not sure
how LVL works, but couldn't
you just send the response
[INAUDIBLE] to your server and
then do something with
that to verify it?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, that's what
I was suggesting, because
it is signed with your
public key, right?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah,
but that bit in the
middle, where the app--
because it goes from our servers
to your application
and then your servers.
The bit in the middle where your
application gets hold of
it can just say, true.
HUGO VISSER: Yeah, but you could
also just check if it
phoned home at all.
If somebody removes that check,
and it doesn't phone
home, or it phones home with the
same value all the time,
that could make it
a bit harder.
It will never be perfect.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There's
always going to be--
just make it a bit harder,
a bit harder.
Eventually, at some point,
it's hard enough.
Other people leave the stock
LVL implementation inside
their application, as well,
so people think
they've cracked it.
But then they have a more
secure [INAUDIBLE].
HUGO VISSER: And one other thing
that I do on forms, if
you try to spam, for example for
the spammer, it looks like
everything works.
But in reality, stuff
doesn't work.
So I can imagine, for this
particular application, that
maybe some things work, and some
things just don't work if
it detects that you have
a cracked app.
NICK BUTCHER: One of my favorite
ones is a partner I
work with who, when they detect
someone's a pirate,
they don't tell or
do anything.
They just make it possible
to finish that level.
The baddies are suddenly
like a bit rock hard.
AL SUTTON: There's one I saw
that enabled the game.
But after playing for an hour
or two, you actually got a
pop-up that took you to the
Play Store and said if you
want to continue, you're going
to have to buy it.
Which is quite a nice
way of doing things.
NICK BUTCHER: Fair
enough, I say.
That's a good strategy.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah,
get them addicted.
Push that on them.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, exactly.
If you pop up a thing saying,
you're a filthy pirate, people
are going to get all defensive
and not going to be
inclined to buy it.
But if you say, hey look, you've
been playing for two
and a half hours, now.
You've got this much progress,
which we'll keep for you.
Just freaking pay the 99p.
AL SUTTON: And don't forget the
picture of you with the
begging bowl.
NICK BUTCHER: Something
like that, I guess.
Anyway, we've been on piracy
for a long time.
Let's move on.
GIUSEPPE: Sorry, sorry again.
It's Giuseppe again.
I like the question
of Peter Brooks.
Has the Google service API got
the Play Store transaction?
This is something that seems
to be interesting.
NICK BUTCHER: I missed that.
Is that in the sidebar?
Has the what?
GIUSEPPE: Has the Google service
API got Play Store
transactions?
NICK BUTCHER: Google
Pay services?
Yeah.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, yeah.
If the Google Play services
could return back to us in the
API the transactions, probably
we can double check if the
application has been paid or is
using something different.
NICK BUTCHER: No, I
don't think it is.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Certainly not
for a paid application, no.
You can't use the Play
Store [INAUDIBLE]
Play Store for an outside
application.
MATT GAUNT: If it's an in-app
purchase, you could get the
list of purchase of
that account.
GIUSEPPE: Yes, correct.
MATT GAUNT: That way, again,
you're still going to then go
on to the root of them stepping
in the middle and
just saying, yep,
he's paid, so--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, but the
new Play Services API doesn't
have anything for paid
applications-- or the new V3--
CHRIS BANES: If you're
externally, trying to check--
is there a Checkout API?
GIUSEPPE: Checkout API, it's
not usable for our
countries, you know.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, I believe
Checkout merchant's
port is only in US and UK.
And they're the only countries
[INAUDIBLE] the API.
GIUSEPPE: Well, one must ask to
the Google service API team
to implement something for
transaction checking.
So please, do that.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Wow.
The topic in my moderator
right now
is a Windows 8 question.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, really?
Going to go for it, Rich?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Well, I
don't know the answer.
I don't have Windows 8, I've
never tried Windows 8.
I saw it in an airport once.
Is it possible to connect an
Android 4 phone with Wi-Fi
Direct to a Windows 8 PC using
Windows networking proximity?
Same question for Windows
7 PC and Namespace API.
I have no idea.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know,
well, Wi-Fi Direct is a
standard, right?
I just don't know of anything
else that implements it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I don't know
what you'd want to run over
the Wi-Fi Direct, necessarily,
once you'd connected your
device to your PC using
Wi-Fi Direct.
NICK BUTCHER: Maybe again,
maybe, yeah, you can send
files or something.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We clearly
have no idea.
All we've used Wi-Fi Direct
for is hooking phones up
directly to play games
and things like that.
NICK BUTCHER: And doing
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And doing
Wi-Fi Direct discoveries.
I've never connected to a PC.
I've connected to a TV, I guess,
because Miracast comes
over Wi-Fi Direct, right?
If anybody has any information
on Windows 8 and Wi-Fi Direct,
send it to Cedric
in Switzerland.
There's only one.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, [? Zerdis ?]
in the moderator asks another
favorite question of
the office hours.
He wants to do a horizontal
list, basically.
He wants to replace gallery,
and horizontal scroll view
isn't an adaptive view.
And he can't use ViewPager to
show multiple views unless he
uses an external [INAUDIBLE],
apparently?
Can you point me to
a good tutorial?
So there are a huge number
of horizontal list view
implementations out there on
GitHub, and code.google.com,
and so forth, each with their
own various implementations
and drawbacks and so forth.
Has anyone used a good one?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BANES: You're talking
about lists, well,
I haven't got that.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Speaking
of horizontal lists.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
horizontal lists.
No, I was going to make a
horizontal bridge view.
But you could do a one--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: One at
a time, please.
CHRIS BANES: He's on the list.
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
OK, [INAUDIBLE]
just dropped out.
We'll go to webcam view.
We'll officially be
back in a second.
Hopefully you can
still hear us.
Somebody nod if you
can hear us.
AL SUTTON: We can hear you.
The second session in the
Hangout now becomes obvious.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It was only
so I could see the chat
window, as well.
One way or another.
MATT GAUNT: So my approach I've
taken with horizontal
scroll view in the past, has
been, I've done it myself with
taking the gallery
source code.
Someone had actually taken
that and wanted to add in
recycling of views.
So there's an example somewhere
on Stack Overflow
where they've posted
a load of code.
If you really want to get your
hands dirty, that might be one
way of doing it.
But it's a lot of extra work.
If you can find the library
on GitHub, then
I'd stick with that.
That would be kind of only
my input on that.
GIUSEPPE: Yossi, Yossi it is
too strange to see you too
late today.
What happened?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, l was waiting
for the Hangout.
And the Hangout was late, so
I went to do other stuff.
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
Yeah, we were.
Sorry about that.
We were seven minutes late today
because we were setting
up in the studio.
I have no other excuse.
Let's go to the next question
in the moderator.
MATT GAUNT: So next question
is, what is the reasoning
behind making the method setText
in TextView final?
And Chris has responded with,
I question why you need to
override the method.
Fair enough.
Yeah, why would it be
defined as final?
And yeah, why would you
need to override it?
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know.
Might check the source to see
if there are any comments.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I would check
the source, as well.
I was thinking that.
MATT GAUNT: Use the source.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I might
check it now.
NICK BUTCHER: That'll
make for good TV.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You can just
hold the thought for a second.
NICK BUTCHER: I hope the is,
clearly, we don't know.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Unless it's
a comment in the source.
NICK BUTCHER: There is another
question in the moderator.
It's Etienne.
It says, I have been able
to implement a custom
MultiAutoCompleteTextView
backed by a
SimpleCursorAdapter with
a custom tokenizer.
I was just wondering, is it
possible to implement this
using the CursorLoader
instead?
I have not done
MultiAutoCompleteTextView.
Has anyone done that before?
I've done a regular one.
MATT GAUNT: No.
NICK BUTCHER: Has anyone got
any experience with that?
I guess it sounds like it could
be possible, instead.
I mean, when you're doing an
AutoCompleteTextView, it's
best if you have a way to
asynchronously fire off a
query against your data
source and return back
a data set to be--
to provide the autocomplete
suggestions.
So you could use the
load infrastructure
for doing that stuff.
But if you've got it working
using, probably, the
AsyncQueryHandler, I imagine,
at the moment, then probably
stick with that.
But I don't see any innate
advantages to moving.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, she's just
posted a Stack Overflow link.
So maybe we can add it to the
comments to see if anyone else
can add another.
NICK BUTCHER: A bit later.
What are you doing Rich?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It looks like
setText is final because it's
the helper method.
There is setText which takes
text and a buffer type, which
isn't final.
So it just fixes the buffer type
on the text that you're
passing in.
NICK BUTCHER: And what
is it passing?
What's the buffer type?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [? M ?]
buffer type.
It's a long file.
NICK BUTCHER: Who is that with
the crazy Android cake?
MATT GAUNT: My guess
would be Yossi.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: It's
me, it's me.
Yeah, guessed it right.
NICK BUTCHER: 10M?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
10 million downloads.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: 10 million
downloads, for who?
CHRIS BANES: Well done.
GIUSEPPE: Bravo, bravo, bravo.
Bravo.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Passes
in buffer type normal.
So setText is final because
it passes in a
buffer type of normal.
But if you want to override
setText, you setText, which
takes the string and
the buffer type.
CHRIS BANES: Rich, is it because
setText is remotable?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Nope.
It's not, is it?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE],
as well?
CHRIS BANES: Well, I hope so.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Or
do you just know
that setText is remotable?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, it
must be, right?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It might
be you're right.
Could be.
CHRIS BANES: There might be
some reflection and stuff
going on in the background,
isn't there?
NICK BUTCHER: Are
there any other
questions that we've missed?
Have they all come in?
MATT GAUNT: I think so.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Finished
up the moderator.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I think
we flied through it today.
PETER BROOKS: I've got
some question here.
NICK BUTCHER: Please.
PETER BROOKS: It's a bit about
the security discussion you
had earlier.
I was wondering, because I'm at
the moment developing some
framework, where the developer
that uses this framework needs
to make some configuration
files.
So we need to give the framework
some key value
pairs, somehow.
And I've wondered, where
would I let the
developer store this?
Since if I understood it right,
if he put it to the
resources, every other app
code accesses via code,
because they are not
private to that.
And of course, that's also what
you mentioned earlier.
I know that anywhere where I
store it on the device, it
won't be safe.
It just obfuscated somehow.
But where could I let him put
it so that it's at least so
much obfuscated that another
app couldn't
access it via code?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So I'm not
quite sure what you mean by if
it's in the resources, another
app would be able to
access it via code.
PETER BROOKS: Yeah. perhaps
that's the first question.
If I got [INAUDIBLE], another
app can have access to the
resources of another app via
the Package Manager Class?
So another app could just--
I thought about some XML file
that stores the configuration.
But that way, another app could
just load it via Package
Manager Class?
Did I got that right, or--
NICK BUTCHER: There are some
areas of your resources which
are accessible.
I mean, that's how you can write
a third-party launcher,
for example, because you can
access each APK's icon,
resource, and things
like this.
I forget-- do you
guys remember?
There's some areas of your
resources which aren't public,
aren't more readable,
and some which are.
And I can't, offhand, remember
which is which.
Has anyone got any--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'm just
looking it up at the moment.
NICK BUTCHER: Everyone's
rapidly Googling.
Beyond that, I mean, any code
resources are obviously going
to be private to the
application.
Could you force them to
implement an interface or
something like this instead?
PETER BROOKS: Yeah, I could,
but I thought it might be a
bit more handy for them, since
I only need key value pairs,
if they could place it in some
XML file or property file.
NICK BUTCHER: What
was that, Chris?
CHRIS BANES: You can
put it in assets.
NICK BUTCHER: So assets
isn't readable,
whereas resources is?
PETER BROOKS: Isn't it?
OK.
Because as I looked, you can get
from the Package Manager
the resource.
And from the resource
class you can also
access the asset directory.
But I might have
got that wrong.
CHRIS BANES: I don't remember
why you can access assets.
NICK BUTCHER: Or is it even
in res.raw, maybe?
CHRIS BANES: I can't remember,
but I thought before there was
one area which is public and
one area that isn't.
But I can't remember, offhand,
which is which.
Don't know if you guys
know, either.
NICK BUTCHER: So is this some
kind of client secret or
something like this that they
need to have in their
application?
Or an identifier of some sort?
PETER BROOKS: Sorry?
NICK BUTCHER: So, what is
the key value pair,
you're trying to--
PETER BROOKS: It's first some
server address that I need to
install, that shouldn't be so
sensitive, and some kind of
application ID to authenticate
against the server.
CHRIS BANES: Can't they just
define it in code?
Can't you just have a hash
mark, and just--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETER BROOKS: Yeah, it could,
but I thought it might be a
bit more handy for the
developers if they use the
framework and they don't
need to write--
because at the moment,
they don't need to
write any other code.
And so this would be just for
configuration, implementing
interfaces, [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, it would work.
CHRIS BANES: So if you write the
framework, and they don't
have to write any code, what
does your framework do?
PETER BROOKS: Synchronizing.
It's for--
should synchronize Java
objects to a server
transparently.
So actually, there should be
only less code, as less code
as possible needed from
the developer.
HUGO VISSER: I wouldn't mind
passing something through code
for configuration, since it
would also [? time ?]
check stuff.
NICK BUTCHER: The standard way
most apps seems to be doing
it-- like Maps API and Backup
Server and stuff--is a
metadata tag in your
manifest, right?
PETER BROOKS: Yeah, that's also
what I thought about in
the first place.
Then I read that you can access
via the Package Manager
[INAUDIBLE].
So I thought it might be nice
if at least other apps can't
access the key via code.
So of course, as long as it's on
the device, you can get it
out there, but perhaps
not via another
application on your device.
NICK BUTCHER: It comes down
to, I guess that's the
convention, so I think that
would be the conventional way
most people will
be used to it.
But yeah, if you would make it
much harder for apps to read
them, then yeah, you could
put it in code.
PETER BROOKS: Thanks, guys.
NICK BUTCHER: You're welcome.
All righty.
Any other questions?
I've seen there's a few in
the G+ thread as well.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'm starting
to look at them now.
Mostly, it's about the privacy
issues, protecting your
application.
NICK BUTCHER: Is there an
example on how to style the
preference widgets from
PreferenceActivity?
I find it difficult to style the
list of radio buttons from
a ListPrefence, for example.
Has anyone done this?
MATT GAUNT: No, I was
always [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
Absolutely not.
I always just make my own.
MATT GAUNT: I thought that
that was the point of
PreferenceActivity, just kind
of does everything for you,
and you kind of--
NICK BUTCHER: It's
a [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You can
choose your theme.
MATT GAUNT: There's a light
theme and a dark theme.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Why would
you want deviate?
MATT GAUNT: I mean, Chris, is
this something you might be
able to do where you could
insert a theme at run time?
CHRIS BANES: I don't know.
I don't know if the preference
styles are
actually public there.
They might be internal.
So I don't think you
can override them.
I don't know.
I've never done it, so
I've never looked.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I'd verge
on the side of not
wanting to do that.
I think there's some utility
to preferences looking the
same and operating the same.
Yeah, you've got the choice of
light or dark, but that's
about it, really.
There is something like unified
preferences, as well,
if you look at the library.
Unified preferences, that's
quite a nice little library
which helps you to do this
kind of thing and produce
fragment-based preferences,
which work across phones and
tablets, as well.
So I think there's some utility
in not doing this,
unless there's a specific thing
you're trying to achieve.
Cool.
I feel like we're running out
of questions, unless there's
anything live.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
Anyone have any last
questions?
I think someone just put
something in the chat window.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh yeah?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I guess,
[INAUDIBLE].
No.
OK.
It's just him saying OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Ah, here's one.
In Java, I can start an
application with my custom
class loader.
Is there a way to do
it in Android?
You can, can't you, right?
Didn't Fred write an article on
the Android Developer blog
about this?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: That was for
loading class files off the
internet and then loading inside
your application with
the class loader, but not
a custom class loader.
I'm not quite sure
what he means.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, you can't
do a custom class loader?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I don't know
what he means by a custom
class loader.
CHRIS BANES: I didn't
think you could
change a class loader.
NICK BUTCHER: No, I don't
think so either.
Think this might be
a Dalvik thing.
Ah, there's a next page of the
moderator questions as well.
Perhaps we hadn't answered
them all.
Answered that one.
Is there any way to accept
some parts of a software
update and reject others,
asks Bob of BBB.
No.
Not unless you're coding your
own kind of update mechanism.
But not through the
Play Store.
Last question.
Cy from Southend says, now
that the protection level
definition of change
configuration has been changed
in Jellybean, breaking apps like
MoreLocale2, is there a
way to change a device
language to a custom
one, such as Welsh?
Anyone know that?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No, I'm
just looking it up now.
NICK BUTCHER: So is this one
of the settings that I
wasn't aware of?
Is this one of the settings that
moved from local settings
to global settings and had
their protection changed?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Allows an
application to modify their
current configuration, such as
Locale since API level one.
What's changed about it?
NICK BUTCHER: The protection
level, it says.
I'm guessing it had gone
to system signature.
CHRIS BANES: Is it the
secure setting stuff?
NICK BUTCHER: That's what I
thought, yeah, with the
multi-user stuff.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It may be
because of the multi-user--
NICK BUTCHER: That's my gut
feeling of what the answer is,
in which case it's the same
answer as we gave before, that
many of these things, it's not
that we've changed it, because
there wasn't ever a very
well-defined API for it.
You weren't supposed
to be able do this.
It's just that you were able to
poke certain settings into
the thing, and behavior
would change.
But it wasn't like it was a
well-defined API that we
guaranteed not to break.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Changing device
language in Locale from
inside an app doesn't sound
like something--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I would
just send the users to the
appropriate screen in
settings, really.
Fire off an intent.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
NICK BUTCHER: I mean, I know for
apps like Locale, that's
not going to be exactly the
behavior you want, but that's
what the platform supports.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
In which case, it's going
on 3 o'clock.
We'ver run out of
questions in the
moderator and the G+ string.
I can finally get this
echo out of my ear.
That feels good.
And thank you for joining
us today.
We'll be back at the normal
time for next
week's office hours.
But then I'm guessing there'll
be a hiatus for Christmas, for
the holiday break for
a couple of weeks.
And we'll be back-- well, we'll
decide by next week when
we'll be back after Christmas.
But thanks, you all, for joining
us again, and we'll
catch you next week.
NICK BUTCHER: Cheers, guys.
GIUSEPPE: Thank you.